JEFFREY POSNICK:
Hey, everybody.
Welcome to this week's YouTube
Developers Live.
I'm Jeff Posnick, broadcasting
from New York.
We don't have any of our
Mountain View colleagues
joining us today.
We have lots of folks
traveling to
really exciting events.
So I'm going to be emceeing
the show.
But we do have some awesome
guests joining us remotely
from Zurich.
And those are Ted Hamilton, who
is the product manager for
YouTube Analytics, and Christoph
Schwab-Ganser, who
is the lead engineer for the
YouTube Analytics API.
And as you might imagine based
on the guests that we have
today, we're going to be really
doing a nice deep dive
on the YouTube Analytics API.
This is a fairly new API that
we announced for the first
time back at Google
I/O in July.
And ever since then,
we've been slowly
adding on some features.
It's been publicly accessible
for a few weeks now.
And hopefully, folks have had
a chance to play around with
it already.
If you haven't, you'll learn a
lot more today and hopefully
get started soon.
So I just want to say hi
to Ted and Christoph.
TED HAMILTON: Hello.
CHRISTOPH SCHWAB-GANSER: Hi.
Hi there.
JEFFREY POSNICK: And thanks
so much for joining us.
So I kind of want to just dive
right in with some questions
for you guys.
And first of all, for folks
who maybe have not played
around with the type of
Analytics data that we
previously offered before
rolling out this YouTube
Analytics API, there was
something called the Insight
Report that you could retrieve
using the older version 2 of
the YouTube GData API.
And this would basically give
you back a really big .zip
file, and the .zip file would
contain a whole bunch of
comma-separated value files
and within those files had
some useful YouTube
Analytics data.
But kind of the whole process
of doing that .zip file
extraction and CSV parsing maybe
wasn't every developer's
favorite way of interacting
with the API.
So I'm curious if you guys could
talk a little bit about
how this new YouTube Analytics
API is different from what we
used to offer with Insight
and what's the developer
experience like if you're
using the Analytics API.
CHRISTOPH SCHWAB-GANSER: So the
new Analytics API allows
you to basically ask precise
questions and then get really
a precise answer, unlike the old
system, which just had a
zip file full of answers, and
you had to find the one which
you were really interested in.
So for example, now we can ask,
what are the views, for
example, for my videos
from Italy.
And you just get this number.
Or you can ask, where was my
video [INAUDIBLE] to, for
example, in what page.
So this is another example
of a query.
So it's really a lot more--
it allows you to make a precise
query, and you get
just the data that
you asked for.
It also allows you to develop
applications like from the web
pages, whereas with a .zip file,
it's not really possible
to pull this from JavaScript.
So that's another advantage.
TED HAMILTON: Yeah, I mean
previously, it would have been
impossible, basically, to make
a dashboard or an app where
you're just looking
up point data.
You'd have to basically download
a CSV, cache it
locally somewhere so
that you could
actually have quick lookups.
But now you can get exactly
the data that
you're looking for.
An Android app, an Android
widget, or iOS, all of that
becomes a whole lot simpler.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Awesome.
And I know that what you
describe with the YouTube
Analytics API's approach, that's
very much in keeping
with something we've talked
about previously in this show,
the new version of the Data
API, where it's a very
targeted set of information that
gets returned, especially
compared to the older Atom
XML response format
that it used to get.
The older version of the Data
API, so kind of using the same
analogy, you're getting exactly
what you want for.
That's obviously better for us
in terms of not having to run
reports and generate metrics
that you don't care about, and
it makes for more responsive
applications.
Also worth pointing out that
it's built on the same sort of
back end that the Data
API is using.
So for folks out there who have
already started their
Data API integration, using
the Analytics API should
hopefully be straightforward
for you guys.
Same set of client libraries,
OAuth 2.0 type of flow.
And hopefully you can build some
really cool applications
that use both of those
APIs together.
So I've noticed that there's
still some statistics that
developers can get
via the YouTube
Analytics web interface.
And those aren't yet exposed via
the API, or weren't until
recently exposed.
I mean, we do have a few
announcements to make
regarding some new
statistics today.
So what's the long-term plan
for the API in terms of
catching up with what you can
get through the web interface?
TED HAMILTON: So basically, the
API should be every bit as
powerful as the web UI.
As a general rule, we want to
enable you to do anything that
you can do on YTA, you can do
analytics through the API,
with the slight exception that
we might be able to put more
experimental data or something
like that on the UI.
But when we put something in
the API, we want it to be
around for a while.
So there might be a
slight lag there.
But for instance, we hear all
the time that earnings data is
missing or audience retention
data is missing.
And we want to find a way to
provide that data so we can
give you everything that you
need to have a complete data
set, basically.
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK.
So definitely patience is
recommended for developers out
there who are waiting for their
specific favorite metric.
TED HAMILTON: Yeah, exactly.
It's not easy to wait, but we
want you to have it as much as
you want to have it.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Absolutely.
Cool.
Another thing that I know that
developers out there have
probably noticed and might have
questions about is the
fact that the Analytics API is
currently marked as being
experimental, which has
a very specific set of
connotations around it.
So what does being an
experimental API mean for
developers, and can you talk
a little bit about what the
process might be for leaving
experimental?
CHRISTOPH SCHWAB-GANSER:
Experimental means that we
still can make changes
to the API.
So basically, you're not bound
to the terms of services that
the other APIs are.
And so we should mention that
we didn't make any breaking
change since we entered
like trusted testing.
And basically, I think the
criteria for leaving
experimental is that we have
confidence in the structure of
the API and basically that we
have enough positive feedback
from partners and developers
that the API's
really what they want.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, so I
guess there might be some
developers out there who see
experimental and say, I don't
even want to bother developing
anything or trying out this
API until that experimental
label goes away.
And it sounds, based on what
you're saying, that would kind
of be a negative reinforcement
cycle where we're looking for
the feedback that we only get
when developers are using
these APIs.
So if they just wait,
we're never
going to get that feedback.
And that might actually delay
the process of removing the
experimental label.
If I can kind of interpret what
you're saying and have
the main takeaway that please,
if you are doing anything with
Analytics, and you're doing
stuff that might use the older
Insight Report in particular,
please start using the YouTube
Analytics API.
It's definitely what the future
of Analytics will be
for YouTube.
It has all the benefits that
we talked about before, and
we're always interested in
getting the feedback while
we're in the experimental
phase.
And even when we leave the
experimental phase, we
obviously still want to hear
what developers have to say
about the API.
TED HAMILTON: I want to
emphasize what Christoph
already said is that
it has been stable.
We have not changed it.
We have to mark it as
experimental because we need
to reserve the right, if we get
feedback from you guys, to
make a slight change.
But this is basically
the model that we
use for our own app.
So we expect it to kind of
stay the way that it is.
And yeah, people, please
do use it.
And if something does change,
it's not going to change
significantly.
So the more feedback that you
can proactively provide, the
better sense that we get for
whether things are working
well or not working.
And of course, we're monitoring
the usage just to
know how that's ramping up.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Cool.
Definitely makes sense.
Can you guys, either of you,
speak to some of the specific
limitations that are currently
in the API around generating
very large reports, maybe
running specific report types
against channels that
have thousands and
thousands of videos?
What's that experience like
today, and what kind of
limitations are in place?
TED HAMILTON: Well, so it's
basically limited by how fast
you can iterate through
the data and of
course your rate limit.
It's not designed to basically
be a data import
functionality, where we
basically just export all of
the data that we have
in our back end, and
you can ingest it.
It's meant to be much more
like precise point lookup
dashboarding type of thing.
And then if you have a
manageable amount of videos,
it works quite well.
But on the far end of the
spectrum, some of our partners
have literally thousands of
channels, and each one of
those has many, many videos.
And so we'll work on a solution
for that type of user
where they can basically
download the data, ingest it
into their data warehouse,
so they can
perform analysis on it.
We're working on that
type of thing.
And that we'd expect to be
probably in the first
half of next year.
So if you have immense data
needs and literally just want
to ingest the data to merge with
your other internal data
or data from other networks or
whatever, that might be a
solution for you.
But it's still a ways off.
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK.
That definitely makes sense.
And I know that I've heard
questions from developers
specifically who weren't
necessarily aware of that
limitation.
We try to spell it
out in the docs.
But for instance, if you are
running certain types of
reports, you could only retrieve
the actual metrics
for the top 10 videos in a
given channel sorted by
decreasing views,
for instance.
So that's the type of limitation
that is in place.
You can't say I want
every single video.
But you can still
run a report.
It's just that it's kind of
limited to the top 10 videos
in your channel.
TED HAMILTON: You can
individually request the data
for every single video.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Absolutely.
TED HAMILTON: But you can't get
a sort of list of beyond
the top 10 for most
things right now.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Right.
OK.
And that's just something we
want developers to know that's
intentional right now, and it's
for all the reasons that
Ted mentioned.
So just be aware of that
limitation for right now.
And we talked a little bit about
this having to do with
how expensive certain
reports could be.
What should developers know
about the way quota works with
the Analytics API?
I know that quota is always a
big topic when we talk about
the Data API.
And people will want to know
what types of calls are more
expensive than others.
How can they kind of optimize
their usage?
Because we obviously do need
to place some limit on the
type of API traffic
that we receive.
So if you could go into a little
more detail publicly, I
know our developers would be
really happy to hear that.
CHRISTOPH SCHWAB-GANSER: Yeah,
basically, our API server does
a variable amount of work
depending on your query.
Basically, it's going to fetch
more or less data on
processes for you.
And basically, this is also
reflected in the amount of
quota that we deduct from
your develop quota.
And we have something documented
on our public
documentation.
And basically, you can say the
more columns or metrics that
you add to your report,
the more expensive the
request will be.
And also, when you get, for
example, for top videos, when
you get a top video report, and
you add many metrics, it's
going to be more like
exponentially
expensive as we look up.
Every value in this table
represents a separate lookup,
and this is reflected in
the quota deduction.
So as a general guideline, it's
good if you just request
only the data that you really
need, of course.
And that you also, if you're
ingesting data in a database,
that you then prepare it for
quota errors, limitations, and
that you have an exponential
backoff based as you rate
limit your request to our API.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
And I'm sure folks might run
into that, people who despite
our disclaimer about this not
really being a data dump, who
do try to do a data dump and get
individual reports one by
one for each video ID in their
channel, let's say.
That's a really easy way to
trigger quota errors if you
keep doing that quickly enough
and you have enough videos.
So do be prepared to kind of
back off in that case using,
ideally, an exponential
backoff.
CHRISTOPH SCHWAB-GANSER: You
can also give us feedback
based on the quota
limitations.
Just tell us if they
are too narrow.
[INAUDIBLE] we are still open,
of course, to your feedback.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, I know
that while we're in
experimental mode, we have a
default amount of quota units
that we're giving people.
And I don't want to speak for
you guys, but I'm assuming we
could kind of be a little bit
reactive in terms of upping
that in general as a default
if things look like
it was set too low.
So that's one of the things I
want to hear about, and I'll
pass it along to the relevant
you guys on the team.
So those are the main questions
that I had.
And we're going to answer some
questions a little bit later
from the Google Moderator
link.
For those who are watching
this live on YouTube, you
should see in the comments a
link to the Google Moderator
queue for any questions.
So this is your chance to ask
questions of Ted and Christoph.
But we'll get to that
in a little bit.
Before we do, I wanted to show
off some of the cool new
things using the Google
APIs Explorer.
So both show off how you can
use the API Explorer to run
Analytics reports, because
not everybody knows that.
And that, in and of itself,
is very cool.
But I also wanted to show off
some of the new metrics that
are now available via
YouTube Analytics.
And I think this is available
as of earlier
today or as of yesterday.
Is that right, Christoph,
some of these things?
CHRISTOPH SCHWAB-GANSER:
Hours ago.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
So, they're so fresh that our
tech writer is working very,
very diligently to try to get
everything documented.
But you won't necessarily
see these things in
the docs quite yet.
That should come shortly.
But nice little perk for tuning,
and you get a sneak
preview of what we're about to
add to the API, or what we
just added to the API.
TED HAMILTON: Hopefully
it works.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, hopefully
it does work.
I think I'm going--
yeah.
So if you take a look at what I
have on my screen right now,
I am using the Google
APIs Explorer.
And this is something that,
it's a public tool that
anybody can go and use.
It takes advantage of being able
to do a nice OAuth 2.0 in
the browser flow.
So I've already authorized
access to this test account
using OAuth 2.0.
But if you go to this for the
first time, you have a chance
to authorize access.
You don't have to put
in your username
and password anywhere.
It integrates nicely
in that regard.
Actually, folks might not be
able to see what the URL is.
But if you go to
developers.google.com, I think
there's a link to the APIs
Explorer at the bottom.
But the main URL is
developers.googl
e.com/apis-explorer.
And you can get there
from here.
So I'm going to show off a
couple of new reports.
These reports are kind of run
against a test content owner
account that we have set up.
This is actually something I
wanted to point out because
this came up recently
in Stack Overflow.
Somebody was asking a question,
and they weren't
quite sure what the syntax was
to use for the IDs parameters
that you see over here--
let me make it
a little bit bigger--
the IDs parameter that's over
here when you're doing a
content owner.
So basically, the way it looks
like is content owner equals
equals and then the name
of the content owner.
It's not a alphanumeric ID.
It's the actual name of
the content owner.
So that's what we're
doing in this case.
We are doing a normal month-long
report with a start
date and end date.
We're making use, in this case,
of some of the new watch
time data that is now available
in the API.
So we're asking for the
estimated minutes watched, the
average view duration,
and the average
view percentage metric.
This is something that people
have been really asking about
since we announced the
Analytics API.
You can now do it,
which is great.
And the dimension in
this case is video.
And we have a filter here to the
videos that we uploaded.
And over here is 10 results.
And we are sorting by decreasing
estimated minutes
watch, in this case.
This is another thing to
point out for folks.
Not everybody--
this also came up on Stack
Overflow once, where somebody
missed that minus sign
that was at the
start of a sort order.
That lets you sort
by decreasing.
So for instance, if you're
doing certain types of
reports, you need to sort
by decreasing views.
So be sure--
that minus sign actually
is really important.
And I actually already executed
this report, that we
could click Execute if you
want to run it yourself.
And what you get back
is your standard
YouTube Analytics response.
For folks who haven't actually
tried the Analytics API
before, you get back
JSON data.
It's pretty easy to parse.
I think you can also request CSV
data, if I'm not mistaken.
I like working with JSON, so
that's the default, and that's
what I'm showing off here.
You get back something that
describes the headers for each
of the columns.
And then you just
get back rows.
So it's kind of like a
serialized version of a report
table, more or less.
Each row, in this case, has the
video ID, the estimated
minutes watched, view duration,
and the average view
percentage, which shows, I
believe, what the average
viewer has viewed of the video,
whether they've viewed
100% or 75% or so on.
So in this particular
case, 48.669%, which
isn't bad at all.
So this is really useful data
for folks who are curious
about how many minutes watched
their videos have had, what
the most popular videos are on
their accounts, according to
minutes watched over a certain
period of time.
And something you couldn't do
before, and something I would
imagine would have been very,
very difficult using the
Insight API.
You certainly couldn't just have
run a report and asked
for those specific
types of metrics.
You would've had to parse a
really big CSV file and kind
of interpret the results
yourself.
So that's pretty cool that
you can do that now.
A couple other things that
I wanted to show off.
This one is making use of the
playback location dimension,
which is now available on the
API for a specific video ID.
And what this will let us do
is get the top 10 videos
sorted by decreasing views--
sorry, get the top 10 locations
for playback sorted
by decreasing values, based on
where they were played back.
So in this case, this is a video
that has presumably been
embedded a few places, embed
over here on Facebook, on
YouTube.com, a few
other sites.
It gives you a real
interesting way of
looking at your data.
You might have embedding enabled
for your videos, and
you want to see where they're
being played back.
It's pretty awesome that
you can do that now.
One other report to show
off, this is a
source of your playbacks.
And I believe if I just scroll
down over here--
OK, the source for traffic
to your videos.
So over here, you can see which
playbacks came from
YouTube channels, people went to
your videos via the channel
versus via search on YouTube
versus via just like organic
Google search versus related
videos versus just
clicking on the URL .
So also really super useful, if
you care about how people
are finding your videos, you
want to see what the top
sources are for people who are
discovering your content so
you could maybe focus a little
bit more on that.
And that's also something there
that you can now do
using the API.
So I'm personally pretty
excited to see
that new stuff added.
Is there anything else that is
notable that I didn't cover in
these demos that you guys wanted
to bring up in terms of
new types of metrics
that are available?
CHRISTOPH SCHWAB-GANSER: These
are the main two features
[INAUDIBLE], so yes.
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK.
And people have been asking us
for that for a while, so it's
really exciting to
see those there.
OK.
So play around with
those demos.
That's a great way to get
familiar with the API without
having to write any
code yourself.
I mean, you obviously can make
all these requests in an
automated fashion using
pretty much any
language of your choosing.
We have other client libraries
that support most of the
popular programming languages
out there.
And if you're running into
questions, either using the
client library or maybe just
something about the Analytics
API is not really clear, and
you're just running into any
sort of issues, I want to make
sure that folks know the right
place to go for any sort of
questions that you have.
And the best place to ask
questions is on Stack
Overflow, which is generic.
It's a good programming
website that folks are
hopefully familiar with.
And if you tag your thing with
YouTube API, YouTube-API, you
should be able to post
a question that
we'll see pretty easily.
So even though this is for the
Analytics API, if you just use
the standard YouTube-API tag,
that would help a lot in terms
of us finding your question.
And we'll answer pretty much
anything that you guys ask.
But there are some things that
are not really questions, and
they might be bug reports or
feature requests, and that
sort of thing is best posted
on our standard
YouTube issue tracker.
So please make use
of that for the
appropriate types of things.
And we do have some resources
for folks who want to get
started with the API.
Lots of people like having
sample code.
So if you go to our
documentation,
developers.googl
e.com/youtube/analytics,
you'll come to this main page.
And over here, on the left hand
side, there's a sample
application.
I must admit that some of
the items in the sample
application are not completely
up to date.
So you'll take a look, and
you'll see step one
through step five.
There are few changes actually
specific not to the Analytics
API but to some of the other
APIs that this uses, namely
the Data API, that were recently
made, which we didn't
have a chance to reflect
yet in the step
by steps over here.
But what we do have at the very
bottom of the page is a
full sample application that's
kind of the full version if
you were to go through all
the steps yourself.
And this has been updated
to be something
that's fully working.
Feel free to take this code,
this JavaScript code.
It gives a pretty cool sample
application that lets you do
real time requesting of data for
specific videos over the
past month and then uses the
Charts API for charting the
view count information
for those videos.
So it's something that we want
to make available just as a
very basic starting place.
There's going to be more sample
code that you should
see over the next few
days slash weeks.
It's definitely our goal to get
as many languages covered
and make sure that people have
a good starting place,
regardless of what language
you're coding in.
So please check that out.
And at this point, I think I
kind of wanted to switch
things over to the Google
Moderator to see if anybody
has any questions from there.
So let's do a refresh.
And OK, so there's one question
over here which I do
not think is specific to the
Analytics API, per se.
But it's kind of a meta-question
about the best
way of going about interacting
with us during these live
broadcasts, let's say.
So it's, "I want to know if
people are broadcasting live
via Hangouts can see the
comments that are posted in
the live message feed.
It would be nice to interact
with the viewers that aren't
included in the Hangout
itself."
So we're actually a little bit
different than a lot of the
other Google Developer live
shows, in that we tend not to
have public Hangouts.
Christoph and Ted are joining us
via Hangout right now, but
it's not just random
audience members.
So we do ask people to interact
with us via this
Google Moderator that's embedded
at the bottom of
every show listing.
So you found it.
That was from Ollie.
You obviously found it.
That's the way to get our
attention during a show.
I know that there is a live
comments feed that you can
post on YouTube.com if you're
watching the video there.
That tends to be watched by our
fearless producer who's
running the whole show.
And if the audio isn't working
or something along those
lines, that's a good thing to
post in the comments feed of
the YouTube video.
But in general, the people who
are on the air don't get to
see anything that's
raised there.
So use the Google Moderator.
TED HAMILTON: That's where you
can call us idiots and stuff,
and then we don't get
distracted by
that during the show.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Exactly.
So fortunately, none of the two
questions that are there
actually call us idiots in
this particular case.
But we have a pretty--
I'm trying to interpret
this question here.
It's kind of about publishing
YouTube videos to a website.
And it's asking whether you
can use Analytics data to
analyze things.
I'm not entirely sure what the
question refers to other than
just the basic fact that, yes,
you can use the YouTube
Analytics API to, for any video,
regardless of where
it's played back, get
information about who's
watching your video.
So take a look at the
documentation, use the API
Explorer, and I think that will
give you, hopefully, what
you need to get started.
TED HAMILTON: I think he might
be asking if you can upload
through the API.
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK.
Yeah, if you're asking about
uploading, that definitely is
part of the Data API.
So that's not necessarily part
of the Analytics API, which
we're talking about today, but
it's part of either the older
Google Data version of the API
or the newer version of the
API which we are calling Version
3, and we recently
also launched.
You can definitely automate the
uploading of videos into
your own channel.
So yep.
TED HAMILTON: And once you do,
you can definitely get the
data for it.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Absolutely.
So we want everything
to be as automated
as possible, ideally.
So a couple of other questions
came in recently.
Can you package OAuth for two
different YouTube APIs in a
single prompt, and the
answer is yes.
So I assume, specifically, the
question has to do with
whether you could ask for both
Analytics permission and
YouTube Data API permission
within a single OAuth 2.0
approval flow.
And that's a really nice
thing about OAuth 2.0.
You can specify as
many, it's called
scopes, OAuth 2.0 scopes.
So you can specify as
many scopes as you
want in a single request.
And you don't have to have the
user see a pop up multiple
times where they say, OK,
yes, I do want to
give Data API access.
Yes, I want to give Analytics
API access,
that sort of thing.
And that actually applies to
any of the Google APIs.
So let's say, I don't know, in
addition to doing YouTube
Analytics, you're also doing
Google Analytics and using the
separate Google Analytics API.
You could put the Google
Analytics API scope in the
same OAuth 2.0 request flow and
do all of that at once.
And there was a question about
where you could download the
example code.
So right now, the sample that
we had on the site is just
linked to from the
main YouTube--
sorry, developers.googl
e.com/youtube/analytics, and
going there, and then going to
the left hand side to Sample
Application.
What we've been doing for the
Data API and we've been
actually kind of successful,
I think, in getting that
started, and I can pull that up
and show what we're doing
there, is trying to do inline
code samples when you look at
the different API methods.
So I believe this is
one that has it.
Yes.
So this is for the Data API.
And you can see that we have
inline PHP and Python samples
right within the page
that documents
the search.list method.
So we're going to first of all
work on expanding our Data API
code samples.
But I think we're going to
also start doing the same
thing for the Analytics API.
And when you go to the page,
that's referenced.
This is a little bit different
because there's really only
one reference page for
the Analytics API.
But ideally, we'll have some
code samples right here on
this page in all the different
languages that you need.
And that's something that we're
hard at work on and
hopefully will make available
pretty soon.
OK.
So we are actually
out of time.
This was a really
fun, full show.
And I just want to thank both
Ted and Christophe.
It's fairly late in Zurich.
And thanks so much for sticking
around and dialing in
and talking about the API.
And hopefully, we'll get some
folks going out there and
writing some code now that makes
use of this cool stuff.
TED HAMILTON: Absolutely.
Thanks for having us on, and
I can't wait to see what
everyone does with the data.
I think this will unlock some
great new possibilities.
So have at it.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Very cool.
OK, until next week,
bye, everybody.
CHRISTOPH SCHWAB-GANSER:
See you.
TED HAMILTON: Bye.